si les élèves se sentent en sécurité à
l'intérieur des écoles la réalité peut
changer rapidement une fois à
l'extérieur
ces cinq adolescentes âgées de 15 ans
affirme que des proxénètes road auprès
de leurs établissements scolaires il y
en a plus mais non leurs cibles sont les
jeunes de plus en plus dont vous auriez
attaquent le second est de trop il
cherche des gens vulnérables puis lors
il les aborde par rapport à genre si tu
as besoin d'argent c'était des provinces
familial je peux aider je fais toi je
vais te ramener chez moi si tu veux je
te faisait d'habitude c'est pas une
surprise parce que le proxénétisme en
fête existe malheureusement depuis
plusieurs années on fait de la
prévention de l'intervention qu'on
collabore avec les différents
partenaires est-ce que yo du
proxénétisme du recrutement qui ce fait
c'est partout à travers l'amérique du
nord nous on s'est pas mis la tête dans
le sable bon de développer un maximum
d'outils ce qu'on voit ce que les gens
savent des choses mais parfois ne nous
appelle pas à l'échelle de la province
le nombre d'infractions liées à
l'exploitation sexuelle n'a cessé
d'augmenter depuis 2015 passant de 764 à
2209 en 2020
le tiers des victimes avaient moins de
18 ans
jinan qui vient tout juste d'avoir 19
ans fait tristement partie de ces
sombres statistiques
j'ai tellement de la journée
exactement c'est un mineur oui mais
combien de clients du peuvent faire par
jour je peux l'enfance 1,6
ça rapportait peur ce n'est pas près des
écoles que son cauchemar a commencé mais
sur internet par une banale demande
d'amitié virtuelle elle avait 15 ans lui
24 ans voulait commencer qui me rajouter
sur facebook j'ai dans ce temps là je me
cherchais facture acheter tout le monde
ça tombait comme gmail danger une fausse
histoire d'amour puis un voyage à
toronto où sa vie bascula tu vas être la
fin de ma vie si tu connais les enfants
à se marier il dit viens avec moi je
suis allé et j'ai toujours nié je jouais
90 aujourd'hui j'ai été et j'en ai fait
des clients puis j'ai j'ai pas honte de
dire j'ai mal les uns mais je pompe sous
l'emprise de son proxénète elle devait
recruter des jeunes filles je pouvais
paraît 2000 par 3000 $ facile vers par
affi que ce que je leur disais pour les
recruter on les a achetés sont faciles à
rattraper c'est quand tu sais pas qu'est
ce que tu fais dans la vie c'est facile
comme ça la fia va y aller
c'est l'homme de ma vie et je ferme à
vis à contenir la vague est tombé dans
la gueule du loup trois ans plus tard
son constat est alarmant tu en vois
beaucoup de jeunes sur des réseaux
sociaux des mineurs qui qui travaillent
oui qui font des clients oui
j'en ai beaucoup si on parle 2009 défi
de quel âge que tu écrives 14
ici à longueuil ou à montréal ou
ailleurs et il y avait beaucoup il ya
remplacé par tous
comme la plupart des adolescents de son
âge les réseaux sociaux ont toujours
fait partie de son identité
mme amara jamais voulu gère les réseaux
sociaux jeune mais quand tu es à un pub
de quelqu'un d'autre cache pas mon
america chutent fsbk cachette
des familles d'application du pta tête
si l'épisode celles qui vont créer une
personnalité plus ça va se démontrer sa
danse et ça va c'est même pas bien c'est
tout en petite culotte avec des footeux
où on est au courant des comptes que nos
enfants secret parce qu'on le demande
mais on a donc convoqué dix depuis la
fin des mesures sanitaires le spvm
remarque une hausse des signalements
reliés à des activités de proxénétisme
la porte d'entrée pour le proxénète qui
veut recruter les feuilles bien voyez
aller par les réseaux sociaux parce que
deux trois clics vont avoir un auditoire
qui at-elle c'est bien plus grand
l'équipe de maya alliés qui s'occupe des
cyber enquête a doublé au cours des cinq
derniers mois passant de cinq à douze
personnes
l'enfant de 14 ans elle va avoir accès à
tous les étrangers toutes les écoles
autour d'elle tous les parcs autour
d'elle et en plus tous les gens qui
m'aiment qui met le même contenu quel
sur les applications mobiles alors
est-ce que c'est facile pour un
proxénète excessivement facile à la
question si elle a beaucoup d' enquêtes
impliquant des mineurs avec un faux
compte il n'ya que ça
c'est la norme
il ya des plateformes que les contenus
sont vraiment éphémère c'est vraiment
c'est là ça disparaisse jeu ça disparaît
c'est cela que les parents devraient
apprendre à connaître le plus on sera
jamais à l'abri de ce type de crime
lottin aussi longtemps qu'il reprend une
meilleure communication entre les
parents et les enfants
faire je pense que c'est localement de
la gare ils sont à part dans ce domaine
sont encore mercredi une double vie qui
laissent des séquelles pour heiteren
s'est dit traumatisée c'est vraiment dur
de l'a7 et puis moi c'est depuis 2002
que jacinthe et l'effet de ma vie qu'est
ce continent sont ils sortis grâce
notamment à un intervenant qui l'a
rencontré à son école secondaire il y a
quelques années
participer à un atelier de
sensibilisation au resserrement
l'exploitation sexuelle ça m'arrivait
souvent des vouloir retourner danser
dans cette vie que j avais toujours la
plage patrick patrick pastèque puis j'ai
fait un peu peur je fais peur
tec est vraiment fait une différence
dans ta vie oui il m'a sauvé toutes les
jambes ce patrick c'est lui un ancien
membre d'un gang de rue qui dédient
maintenant sa vie à aider les jeunes on
se réveille toi en velin sépare se
rouvrant voir des responsabilités on
veut se sentir important j'essaie de
créer des rêves puis tout le monde des
rêves fac si je te parle à toi je trouve
c'est quoi ton rang
c'est de le faire l'os et on râle c'est
comme une course à qui tu m'offres en
gros il aura en premier
fragile encore vulnérable la force de
ginals se retrouve dans sa détermination
à s'en sortir j'ai qu'un gros
je fais pour aider les enfants
j'ai fait pour aider les parents aussi
parce que mon moment qu'elle l'ait
jamais reçus puis aller sur un papier du
tribunal
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on n'en parlait
pas à en libérer
[Musique]